so this is more differentiation of the
archetype fundamentally so you see the
dragon of chaos here the potential
manifesting itself into this ambivalent
feminine figure both both promise and
threat and then I've mapped this one out
so the ambivalent feminine figure so
sort of multivalent gives rise to the
positive mother and then the positive
mother gives birth to the hero and
that's Hercules there and this I like
this image a lot so Hercules is in this
container so that's that you can
interpret that both has something
feminine in the container but also as a
representative of culture because it's a
boat that's floating on the chaotic
ocean here so that's Hercules he has to
be in a container that sustains him in
the murky water of chaos and you see
he's going out into the unknown and he's
got a lion skin on and that's partly
because one of the initiation rituals
for her young men when the reliance say
in the Middle East and that wasn't very
long ago is that you had to go out to
kill a lion with a spear or with a bow
and arrow or something like that it's
like that's you know impressive all
things considered I mean you really
think about that for a minute you really
want to go out try to kill a lion with a
stick it's like it probably you probably
wouldn't be quite the same after you did
that that would be my guess
and so anyway so there's Hercules has
got his lion skiing on and that shows
that he's assimilated to the lion the
dominant sort of animal and that he's
also mastered it and he's got his bow
and arrow so he's he's going to hit the
target properly he's not he's someone
who doesn't sin because he can hit the
center of the target and he's got this
Club which I really like because it's
covered with eyes just like Marduk mr.
potamia here oh well what do you want to
do when you go out into the unknown it's
like arm yourself and pay attention and
so that's what you're trying to produce
if you're good mother is this figure
that can go out into the unknown armed
accurate and able to pay attention and
that's a hell of a thing to participate
in it's really fun I have found having
children incredibly entertaining it's
ridiculously entertaining thing to do
because for a bunch of reasons one is
that it's the only relationship you'll
ever have in your life where you where
you actually have a chance of
establishing something that's close to
perfect is with your kids because when
they're delivered to you so to speak
they're there in
since they're perfect and your job is to
maintain that perfection if you can and
you do that by being a good parent by
being encouraging by being on their side
by taking care of them and you can have
a absolutely pristine relationship with
the child that doesn't mean it's not
full of trouble because it is but it's
it can easily be the best relationship
you'll ever have in your life and in
fact I think that's it could be the
worst - and you know sometimes you get
unlucky and your child is sick mentally
or physically and things fall apart and
it's not your fault but and sometimes it
is your fault
but it's a real gift and you have to
play this game of protection and
encouragement right protection and
encouragement and get that dynamic right
and then you build you help someone
develop into something that's well
exactly this that can take on the
trouble of the world forthrightly and
man that's what you want
that'll make it worthwhile that's for
sure